[Musik]
eine ärztin im kampf mit der zeit china
holt schwer kranke patienten aus der
ganzen welt zurück nicht nur das leben
retten
ich bin erwachsen geworden weil ich
eigentlich spaß gehabt zu helfen
jeder auftrag ein hilferuf in den
sommermonaten ist ihnen mit ihrem team
von der flugrettung rund um die uhr im
einsatz
[Musik]
ein notruf 112 jetzt entscheiden minuten
notfallsanitäter nico und sein kollege
müssen schnell sein
im rettungswagen der berliner feuerwehr
sind sie immer zu zweit
[Musik]
ein notarzt wird bei sehr kritischen
einsetzen extra alarmiert bekommt oft
geht es um leben und tod
ich finde es schon wunderbar dass die
leute überhaupt den notruf gewählt haben
ja dafür sind wir dann im endeffekt
darum herauszufinden geht es der person
schlecht oder nicht
[Musik]
die einsatzzentrale der flugrettung teil
der ambulanz in innsbruck ständig
bekommen ärzte und piloten aufträge für
rettungseinsätze in der ganzen welt
china ist anästhesistin intensiv und
notfallmedizin sie hat familie und lebt
in bonn
kurz vor abflug gibt es immer noch etwas
zu erledigen
auftraggeber der flugrettung sind
versicherungen
sie lassen ihre verunglückten oder
schwerkranken patienten abholen und
zurück in ihre heimatländer fliegen
das tag beginnt mit einem flug nach
lissabon mit dem jet um die welt zu
fliegen ist ja eine geschichte dass ich
in andere länder komme in anderen teams
arbeite andere kulturen kennenlernen und
sehe wie woanders gearbeitet wird man
horizont erweitern landung in lissabon
ein krebskranker mann 92 jahre alt brite
wartet in einem krankenhaus auf seinen
rücktransport der alte herr ist bei
einer kreuzfahrt zusammengebrochen
china wird ihn intensiv medizinisch
versorgen müssen
[Musik]
wenn jemand wenn ihr mann total krank
ist dass der stärken könnte auf dem flug
dass man darüber redet und dass sie
angehörigen auch der ganz einverstanden
sind auch neben falls der patient dass
wir den transport hatten wir dann auf
bitten dass sie darunter unterschreiben
dass sie das risiko kennen und auch
akzeptieren austausch mit den ärzten vor
ort die diagnose ist besorgniserregend
die zeit drängt um das leben des alten
herrn zu retten
die ehefrau wird noch vor ort über den
kritischen zustand von ärzten ina
aufgeklärt
aber aufgeben will ihn noch lange nicht
ich bin immer für meine patienten da ich
werde auch immer für meine patienten
kämpfen
genau wie ich für meine familie und
meine freunde kämpfen ich gebe dann
immer alles bis aufs letzte
ich bin eigentlich ganz guten mutes dass
ich eben rüber krieg
von oestrich
dem alten herrn geht es immer schlechter
und sie haben noch fast vier stunden
transport vor sich da ist jemand der
kann sich nicht alleine helfen wer ist
krank und er braucht hilfe
da kann ich nicht nur mit zehn prozent
dann muss ich doch mit 100 prozent
fahren hier hat er doch verdient das
kommt aus mir raus ich finde das ist
eigentlich das richtige
keine materiellen zugang gelegt um zu
wissen
ja
oben in der luft damit das gleich mal
messen können im blut raus oder machen
und ginge auch andere informationen wie
zb das aktuelle labor oder zu können und
so weiter und so fort
damit wir wissen was wir eben keinen
schaden zufügen
bg 100 ist ein ambulanzflugzeug
ausgestattet mit modernen
intensivmedizinischen geräten inklusive
labor
[Applaus]
landeanflug auf southampton
der patient muss jetzt noch mit der
fähre auf seiner heimatinsel isle of
wight gebracht werden
china ist seit sechs monaten bei der
team em bilanz aber schon zehn jahre bei
der flugrettung ein arbeitstag kann
schon mal 16 stunden lang sein
ich mag extremsituation also wenn es
richtig wenn es richtig anstrengend ist
man richtig viel denken muss und wenn
man neu organisieren muss und das macht
einfach spaß und das ist die
herausforderung ich wenn ich jeden tag
in den gleichen op kriegen gehe dann
wird mir langweilig und so gehe ich aber
mit dem gleich also mit mit einem team
mit dem hier bekannten team das auch
schon mal wechseln kann
in ganz neue situationen
feste arbeitszeiten gibt es für ihn
nicht sie ist schon seit zehn stunden
für und mit dem schwerstkranken
patienten unterwegs
einsatz am alexanderplatz in berlin
ein anonymer anruf notfallsanitäter nico
und seine kollegen sind zu betrunkenen
obdachlosen gerufen worden
ich hab da überhaupt keine vorurteile
oder berührungsängste gegenüber der hand
menschen die jetzt vielleicht nicht so
im sozialen umfeld gefestigt sind wie
ich ja da muss man einfach ran wenn der
mensch hilfe braucht dann brauche hilfe
und wenn es dann halt einfach nochmal
das handauflegen ist weil der zuspruch
braucht
das wort lebensretter also immer so
schön gesagt aber warum bin ich geworden
definitiv einmal familiäre veranlagung
sage ich einfach mal wie es ist ja ich
bin damit groß geworden
mein vater es bei der feuerwehr meine
mutter ist gelernte arzthelferin
ich komme mir das ganze auch halt
kennenlernen im vorfeld und somit ist
der beruf mein traumberuf fenstersturz
studio b im ersten og
[Musik]
nicos rettungswagen ist nach fünf
minuten vor ort die lage muss kritisch
seien auch ein notarzt wurde alarmiert
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor mitternacht hinter der
mauer auf dem dach einer remise liegt
vermutlich eine schwer verletzte person
[Musik]
nico weiß nicht was er hinter der zehn
meter hohen mauer vorfindet ist die
person überhaupt noch am leben
während nico oben die lebensbedrohlich
verletzten versorgung einleitet bereiten
seine kollegen unten alles für ihren
abtransport vor so viel ist gewiss es
ist eine junge frau die aus dem fünften
stockwerk gestürzt ist sie lebt noch hat
aber schwere verletzungen und ist nicht
mehr bei bewusstsein
notarzt und einsatzkräfte schaffen die
schwerverletzte auf der vakuummatratze
über die drehleiter nach unten
12 rettungskräfte und der notarzt sind
vor ort
ein einsatz von dieser größenordnung hat
micro als notfallsanitäter noch nicht
erlebt die patientin wird jetzt
künstlich beatmet
[Musik]
weiblich ca 25 jahre zustand noch
fenstersturz und klare höhe intubiert
beatmet und traumatisiert
die junge frau ist vorerst gerettet im
krankenhaus werden ärzte sie sechs
stunden lang operieren und um ihr leben
kämpfen
sie hat zudem eine
wirbelsäulenverletzung und ein schweres
hirntrauma man bei einsätze haben
großteils schon um leben und tod ging
sage ich mal her wir den patienten leben
ins krankenhaus gebaut haben da kann man
sagen was man nicht glücklich wir haben
für uns ich sag mal dass menschen
möglichst haben ja nicht einfach zu
sagen haben sie lebend ins krankenhaus
gebracht und was dort passiert wie die
prognose ist dass gute zeiten
das leben von menschen halten inne hat
wieder einen neuen einsatz
die norton junger mann ist um 80 geboren
er ist geklettert aber endlich
unser weggerutscht und hat sich den
unterschenkel gebrochen
das ist informationen die wir haben er
ist unterversorgt den ferien kann man da
von hier sehen wir die patienten von
dort weg geholt der flughafen in tiflis
der patient ist schon zum flugzeug
gebracht worden
dadurch sparen sie wertvolle zeit der
junge mann kommt aus tschechien sein
bein ist mehrfach gebrochen es wurde
notdürftig versorgt zur weiterbehandlung
wird der 32-jährige nach linz in
österreich geflogen
in eine spezialklinik seine freundinnen
darf ihn begleiten
nicht immer ist ein platz für angehörige
frei
der junge mann erzählt ina seine
geschichte er war mit freunden im
kaukasus wandern als er sich auf einem
feld setzte stürzte er mit ihm in die
tiefe seine freunde brachten ihn fünf
stunden lang auf einem pferd in den
nächsten ort
die tyrol air ambulance transportiert
jährlich circa 2.000 patienten auf ihren
flügen weltweit innerhalb europas kostet
so ein ambulanzflug je nach
bestimmungsort 8000 bis 25.000 euro
die kosten übernimmt seine auslands
krankenversicherung
sagt jemand danke seine ist eine große
eine große emotionale befriedigung noch
mal zu sehen dass das was ich tue auch
von den patienten auch bemerkt wird
nach den oft dramatischen
rettungsaktionen wartet das hotel ein
leben aus dem koffer im schnitt 14 tage
im monat
das handy ist das wichtigste verbindung
zur familie in bonn
sie hat zwei kinder ihr mann ist auch
arzt ina hatte 13 jahre lang eine
festanstellung im krankenhaus dahin
möchte sie nicht zurück sie haben auch
das andere extrem kann wo ich morgens in
die klinik gegangen bin abends wieder
heim gekommen bin
mit sechs bis zehn diensten pro monat 24
stunden wo ich dann eigentlich nur müde
war schlecht gelaunt so bin ich halt
nicht da wenn ich arbeite aber wenn ich
dann da bin ich da
wieder in der rettungswache der berliner
feuerwehr in mitte
nico hat heute tagschicht als
feuerwehrmann
der 26 jährige hat nach seiner
ausbildung zum brandmeister dann noch
den abschluss zum notfallsanitäter
drangehängt
für beides muss er fit sein nico
arbeitet manchmal rund um die uhr
er hatte allein in den letzten vier
monaten über 200 überstunden der alarm
kommt von einem brandmelder das heißt
ausdrücken in voller montur bei
notfallsanitäter geht es um das
medizinische hier um das technische ich
mir schon einfach gut
also ich habe den vorteil dadurch dass
ich halt auch feuerwehrbeamte bin dass
ich ganz einfach auf dem geschoss sitzen
kann und das was mein kindheitstraum
ausleben kann also feuer spielen eine
brandmeldeanlage hat in der tiefgarage
eines bürohauses alarm ausgelöst
das haus wurde geräumt fehlalarm
nico und seine kollegen müssen gar nicht
erst aussteigen die angestellten können
an ihre arbeitsplätze zurückkehren
das passiert in berlin-mitte vier bis
fünf mal am tag ein neuer einsatz ein
kleiner brand im volkspark
friedrichshain soll gelöscht werden
1500 alarme pro tag die berliner
feuerwehr ist die älteste und größte
berufsfeuerwehr deutschlands
hier spielt nur weggeworfenes grillgut
so ein einsatz kostet über 150 euro er
wird nach minuten berechnet
auch jeder bürger ganz normal selber
ausmachen können wir sind alle richtig
aber was soll man tun wenn man kommt
kriegt man hier noch blöde sprüche von
soeben noch selber ausmachen können oder
das bisschen mangelnde wertschätzung
aber auch behinderungen und gewalt gegen
rettungskräfte nehmen zu dazu kommt die
schlechte bezahlung
ich wusste dass ich bei der feuerwehr
nicht reich werden am tag verdient hier
in berlin als brandmeister 2009 eur
brutto ungefähr
damit wird man nicht reich wenn man dann
sage mal die krankenversicherung abzieht
wir sind privat versichert und dadurch
wusste ich dass ich definitiv nicht
reich werden
das ist auch gar nicht japan mein
ansporn
[Musik]
nicos ansporn ist es menschen in not zu
helfen
[Musik]
in seiner freizeit trifft sich nico
öfter mit seinen freunden sascha und
andreas von der freiwilligen feuerwehr
seit seinem achtzehnten lebensjahr
gehört er dazu
beruflich menschenleben retten die
überzeugung kam für ihn nach einem
großbrand in neukölln vor sechs jahren
ein schlüsselerlebnis im hinterhaus
hatte jemand einen kinderwagen
angezündet das ganze treppenhaus brannte
die menschen waren in ihren wohnungen
eingeschlossen andreas erinnert sich
valentin war hektik waren menschen
standen an den fenstern und und schrien
und ich dachte mir so ungefähr muss
krieg gewesen sein
bei diesem einsatz gab es insgesamt drei
tote säugling die mutter und der onkel
und 615 verletztheit gewesen und es war
schon ein einsatz der personalintensiv
alt war und einer der größeren einsätze
also an seine persönlichen grenzen kommt
man relativ schnell wenn es halt um
einsätze geht bei denen es um kinder
geht zum beispiel habe ich für mich
persönlich festgestellt
vergessen kann man solche einsätze
definitiv
also wer auch glaube ich falsch irgendwo
so einen einsatz zu vergessen also
meiner meinung nach würde damit der
psyche einfach etwas nicht stimmen
und das wäre einfach so ein schutzreflex
verein der ist sowas vergessen würde
und ich finde es halt besser wenn man
regelmäßig über sowas spricht ja mit
denen die dabei waren auch das einfach
zu verarbeiten
nach den anstrengenden einsätzen ist ina
an den wochenenden zu hause bei der
familie
die kinder emil und gloria sind zehn und
16 jahre alt ihr mann rudi ist chefarzt
für orthopädie und unfallchirurgie als
ärztin im krankenhaus wariner nicht
zufrieden
bei der flugrettung ist die voll
engagiert aber eben weit weg ich habe
mir immer so ein bisschen sorgen gemacht
um sie weil sie das ebenso gerne macht
uns immer als 490 es wie gesagt nicht
kennen stellen sich darunter vor man
fliegt man zehn tage in der
weltgeschichte durch die gegend und
einem sehr netten plätzen aber wie von
kuala lumpur über nordamerika bis
südafrika aber das fliegen in einem
kleinen flugzeug nachts das losfliegen
nicht genau wissen was kommt da auf
einen zu völlig unregelmäßig dann ist
das sehr anstrengend
ich kenne ja die na wenn man das so
macht wie ihn mit dem anspruch sie will
das richtig machen
das ist eine große verantwortung ein
balance akt zwischen beruf und familie
schon jetzt müsste eigentlich doch
besser sein als letzte woche war dann
zum beispiel ein schulfest davor die
woche war ne wenn das war das abschieds
fester folie woche war das schulfest und
ich war immer nicht da so wenn ich dann
schon mal in die schule komme dann
denken die anderen mütter auch um gottes
willen ich bin so eine rabenmutter ich
bin nie da
weil ein für die gemeinsame zeit mit der
familie ist kostbar und wird gut geplant
eigentlich haben wir nur diese
wochenenden wenn man sonst so wenig zeit
zu sagen hat das auch irgendwie so ja so
erlebnis punkt geschafft es muss nichts
großes sein aber dinge die dann eben
besonders werden weil wir zusammen sind
abschalten von beruf ehefrau und mutter
seien am wochenende
ina muss prioritäten setzen
die zeit mit der familie ist meist zu
kurz aber sie gibt der 49-jährigen kraft
für die nächsten anstrengenden einsätze
am sonntagabend auf dem weg nach
innsbruck jetzt lieben 600 kilometer
nachtfahrt vor ihr ihre familie muss für
eine woche ohne sie auskommen
eine kinderfrau gemacht man könnte das
alleine sicherlich nicht schaffen er
arbeitet ja auch zwölf 13 stunden am tag
regel jeden ist hier und hat die zügel
in der hand und mein vater ist ganz ganz
toll eingebunden ich würde mal sagen das
familienleben wird von den beiden
gemacht
hochbetrieb
die sechs flugzeuge der tlm bilanz sind
ausgebucht für das team sind gleich drei
einsätze hintereinander geplant mit
übernachtungen in london nicht so ganz
also bei dieser gesellschaft aber ich
kann mich komplett auf alle verlassen
auch die piloten wie auch auf die pflege
weil einer für alle alle für einen
zeit zum essen und für entspannung gibt
es eigentlich nur auf den flügen für die
crew
anflug auf kreta 80 prozent aller
kranken die sie zurückbringen sind
intensivpatienten
viele von ihnen werden erst noch vom
krankenhaus abgeholt
die internationale zusammenarbeit muss
gut organisiert werden
im job habe ich natürlich auch fünf
konflikten zu tun man muss sich als frau
doch ein bisschen mehr beweis leitsatz
mann und dann muss man schon mal sagen
es geht genauso wie ich das jetzt will
eine 81 jährige britin mit einem
oberschenkelhalsbruch braucht ihre hilfe
die frau wurde in der klinik nur
notversorgt sie will sich lieber zuhause
operieren lassen
ihr zustand ist kritisch
art sein oder auch pfleger wein ist ja
eine art berufung wir arbeiten am
menschen
und wenn es den menschen gut geht dann
geht es uns damit auch gut
die patientin wird von einer ärztin und
einer krankenpflegerin abgeholt die ihre
sprache sprechen und sie heim bringen
und anteil an ihrem schicksal nehmen
[Musik]
auf dem flughafen heraklion hat die crew
fast vier stunden auf die ankunft des
krankenwagens gewartet endlich kann der
flug nach london angetreten werden
der dauert noch einmal vier stunden zeit
um die patientin auf kleinstem raum so
gut wie möglich medizinisch zu versorgen
im flugzeug sind in unsere ressourcen
ein bisschen begrenzt was wir auch an
equipment dabei haben und da muss man
manchmal auch improvisieren
das ist eine form der kreativität also
man kann mit ganz vielen dingen arbeiten
das führt nicht immer nur ein blick zum
ziel es führen immer mehrere wege zum
ziel
die patientinnen dich hin zu bewegen
sauerstoffgehalt im blut
das sieht man jetzt daran der 89 das und
das ist und jetzt bist du von mir ein
bisschen dauer stopp in die nase
in der flugrettung sind die patienten
sehr sehr dankbar wenn wir jemand nach
hause bringen da sind wir eine bleibende
erinnerung
[Applaus]
super
in ordnung fahrzeug direkt übernehmen
[Musik]
sieben uhr morgens bei der feuerwehr in
berlin mitte
nicos tragschicht hat begonnen noch ist
keine anforderungen für den
rettungswagen gekommen
zeit für das frühstück auf der wache
versorgen sich die kollegen selbst bin
ja nun auch nicht der leichteste man
muss halt wirklich nur dabei aufpassen
dass es soweit im rahmen bleibt dass man
diesen sogenannten body-mass-index wenig
feuerwerke vorschreibt damit die leute
halt fit bleiben dass man sie nicht
überschreitet und ja gesagt sport
zwischendurch und dann passt es halt
auch mit meiner frage ich mal kräftige
körperstatur
[Musik]
rührei gehört zum standard und thunfisch
die sogenannte feuerwehr marmelade also
hackepeter haben sie zugunsten der
gesunden ernährung gestrichen
jetzt erstmal aus
die sind meist zu dritt auf den
ausgleich bei der derzeit den notfall
seiner ausbildung gemacht und da wird
auch heute mit den patienten auch in
polen das heißt nico ist heute sein chef
und hört ihn an leighton zum einsatz
gehört der kampf durch das alltägliche
chaos auf berlins straßen
wichtig ist einfach dass man entspannt
bleibt wenn man selber mit blaulicht
durch die gegend fährt
es gibt die verschiedensten internet sei
es wie gesagt dass die leute auf anfahrt
zum notfallort einfach keine
rettungsgasse bilden an roten ampeln
stehen bleiben muss den weg versperren
obwohl sie einfach überfahren dürfen wir
den moment
wie gesagt man muss ruhig bleiben muss
dann spannend werden ja das ist ein
johnston das eine mal stress den ich mir
rumschleppen
das klingt mir mit der zeit einfach gar
nichts trotz aller hindernisse kann der
rettungswagen die vorgeschriebene zeit
von acht minuten bis zum einsatzort
einhalten so ein einsatz mit dem
rettungswagen inklusive transport ins
krankenhaus kostet 319 euro der junge
mann leidet an morbus crohn er hat
starke schmerzen und ist kurz vor dem
zusammenbruch
ok also die seit montag brauchen wir
dann auf jeden fall müssen jetzt
vervollständigen und to you tube bis 130
der erfolg um rat wenn wir soweit alles
vervollständigt haben zugegeben die
komplette vorbereitung in der
zwischenzeit seinem kurztrip nach berlin
hat sich der junge mann sicherlich
anders vorgestellt als notfallsanitäter
kann nico dem jungen mann vorerst keine
schmerzen und auch seine ängste nehmen
man muss definitiv ein party haben
dem ruf des sanitäters oder
allgemeinheit im bereich der rettung
man kommt einfach in situationen wo
menschen als größtes leid empfinden ja
schlimme situationen sich
und da braucht man nicht viel empathie
[Musik]
ina und ihre crew sind nach zwei langen
arbeitstagen über griechenland england
nordafrika und frankreich wieder in
innsbruck gelandet
da ist jemand richtig schwer
verunglückte ist schlecht versorgt in
diesem land nehmen wir meinetwegen
marokko tunesien also viel hinter
mittelmeer als schlecht versorgt und wir
bringen jemanden nach hause und die
angehörigen sind unglaublich dankbar und
der patient dann zum schluss auch wenn
das geschafft hat und überlebt hat dann
bin ich total glücklich dass man das
geschafft hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]